So let us see in the workshops list uh component
uh how we'll write a test to test that uh
the loading message should show up initially when the workshops
list component loads that uh shows up uh we are
fetching workshops That message should show up I'll check the
VS code I'm in the folder which is the project
folder Workshops are And we'll create a file if it
is not already there You may already have this file
It is uh right next to workshops list We'll create
a workshops lists.js So first of all we need to
import the workshops list component Then we would need to
import render from React uh uh testing library Oh then
we would uh have to Start of the test It's
better to group the test using describe So we'll use
a describe block which is used in uh just to
group test or just uh uh Jasmine just uh in
the GST framework it's used to group test So you
can write many tests within a described block So that
forms a test specification or a test we actually sorry
That's sweet So this is workshops uh list initial uh
page load test or Mm Buckshop's list Initial page note
So we need to test 3 things under this One
that the loading message shows up which we're going to
do now Then the workshops if fit successfully after that
they are shown or if there's an error the error
message is shown These 3 tests will be part of
this test week So and describe the second document will
be a function inside which you'll write the test The
test can be written either using IT function it literally
the English word it or the test function So that's
your preference so you write it The test that we
are going to write right now is that it should
uh show the loading message initially The second argument is
a function So we need to render Uh the workshops
uh list Now the workshops list component Doesn't have any
special requirements So we can load it directly Special requirements
in the sense it's not using some other library like
React router uh Dome is It is using React router
down the link so we have to wrap it up
in a browser router So whenever we have a link
being used link cannot be used outside a browser router
So because of that requirement we'll put inside a browser
router Browser router is imported from react router down We'll
put our workshops list component Otherwise generally we'll just render
our component But uh links cannot be used outside the
browser router uh context so you'll have to give that
So we have rendered whatever we have to If you
didn't have link we would have just done directly like
this just a workshops list After having rendered it using
React Testing library's render method we basically it's like similar
to rendering in a browser environment it'll get rendered It's
uh some DOM environment which just creates using just um
framework So a browser-like environment it renders itself Now we'll
test the uh whether the loading message appears So for
that we need to give some kind of test ID
So we have to uh test whether this is appearing
this loading message Now this already has a data test
ID So this is very specific to reactor testing library
You can give a custom attribute data test ID It's
very similar to giving an ID or uh an element
in HTML So this is an ID given just for
the purposes of testing It should be unique again So
loading message we'll try to find out if there's any
element with that test ID So how do we do
that in uh react testing library uh we have to
say screen where screen we have to input from react
testing library It's similar to what you do in HTML
like document in JavaScript document so screen There are various
query methods similar to again like you have get element
ID query selector similarly you have various uh queries uh
under the screen object Get my test ID is what
we'll be using This is not the preferred way generally
There are better ways We'll see why certain things are
better This is the least preferred ones one but we
can start using this because it's straightforward Later we'll see
other ways So get my test I is what we're
using now Later we'll see other query methods So this
gives us access to That element And we can test
if it exists in the DOM this element whether we
were able to fetch it because really that means we
have queried and got it So it should be in
the document And uh yes DOM is a uh uh
a library which comes pre-installed with the create reactor and
uh that has different matches like to be in the
document So we can expect So I expect it just
uh just uh method for uh sessions So you'll put
in whatever this element and then you have these match
functions which come from GE do so to be in
the document And why we are able to use this
matcher this is not a matcher which isn't jest Just
as certain matches like you can see if you go
to justj.org Sorry just to start are you You can
see there are certain matches and just OK you see
the matches here Some matches are explained here and the
reference to all the matches is here And you see
these are all the matches We don't see anything like
to be in the document even if you search out
here to be in the document In the document you
don't find it I'm searching here You have other things
like to be less than to be greater than to
be equal to be etc but to equal but you
don't have to be in the document This comes actually
from another library called JSDO That's your yes no And
uh you can see the different matches here You'll find
to be in the document To be in the document
How come we are able to use this matcher even
though we're not included it Uh that's because Uh the
first test before any test script runs test file runs
there is a setup test this In the create your
tab you have the setup test this If you write
a file like this inside the SRC folder It should
be called setupt.s with the case incorrect Then it will
run before every unit test file and here GO has
already been included It's create react app has already downloaded
it at the time of creation of the application and
it's imported it Therefore we are able to use it
Therefore we are able to use to be in the
document Now this test is complete Let us run it
So to run it we have to be in the
project folder We are in the project folder workshops app
And uh we have run NPM test Few changes uh
have been we can make to uh this In fact
it's already made so you can see react script test
is what you would find as a test script in
the default create reactive application We've added hyphen and silent
which will suppress some warnings uh because react testing library
gives a lot of warnings which are actually uh not
uh real warnings It's OK It's even they explain that
is reactor testing that they explain that they're not real
warnings If you want you can show the warnings but
it'll be a little annoying so you can remove this
if you want I have maintained hyphenated silent which will
remove the warnings and show only errors Verbos which will
give like uh more uh lengthy descriptions of the test
results of what passed what failed etc and hyphen FN
coverage which will also give a coverage report that is
how many lines of code were covered in the test
So having made these modifications you can make these Uh
and also coverage script is added that only if you
want only coverage and it only with coverage and I'll
show the coverage report Having done these changes now if
you run the test You can see that it passed
This proves that uh the loading message shows up on
initial page load Let us actually make it uh to
see the test is effective We'll go to the component
workshop list JSX And uh we will make a change
so that the loading message doesn't show up So we're
saying if while it's loading it should show this up
right So let's say that we remove this Let's say
a developer comes and comments this out or removes this
so it will not show up now And your test
will fail So it should show the loading message that
test fails Unable to find such an element So it
could not find that after the uh component loaded So
this proves that your test is effective So now we'll
get it back I will save the file And the
test has started passing again So that completes this test